How can we, speaking here
to the religious scholars and those responsible
for them,
truly pause and reflect on the
current situation? I've spoken about this topic once,
twice before. We must seriously consider the
state we're in. It's inconceivable that the
ideology we're criticizing could drive
this entire nation to become a source of anxiety, strife, and
destruction for the whole world. It's impossible that
this ideology—and I'm not talking about religion, but about this
ideology that has been sanctified—texts and ideas that have been
sanctified for hundreds of years, making it incredibly
difficult to deviate from them, to the point that they are hostile to the
entire world. Are 1.6
billion people going to kill the entire world of 7
billion just so they can live? This is unbelievable.
I'm saying this here at Al-Azhar,
here before religious scholars and men. I swear to God, I will be held accountable
before God Almighty on the Day of Judgment
for what I'm saying now.
You can't possibly be inside it, feeling it. You can't be
inside it, feeling it. You must break free
from it.  You watch it and read its truly enlightened thought.
You need to stop this drastically. And I'm saying it
again, we need a
religious revolution. The Imam's virtue is that
you are responsible before God. The
whole world is waiting for you. The whole world is waiting for
your word
because this nation is
being torn apart, this nation is being destroyed,
this nation is being lost, and we are the ones who are
losing it.